welcome to this video need to restart
this having a quite some problems with
my voice I hope it doesn't tell me
during the recording I think what I just
ate for dinner was a little bit too hot
okay um a Slav hmm ok let's go with the
chobani ankle variation a 64 hmm yeah
i'm playing e6e em but briefly thinking
if there is something else yeah 85 mm is
a no idea that I always liked him it
gives ya Quincy to it's a bit of a
strange move because night before some
blacks plan anyway so I'm basically
gifted a temple here we go yeah the
night is some sitting nicely on before
and dumb it is very bit difficulty in
the structure for white to get anything
going on the on the queenside which is
of course the natural place to play in a
way then the Queens gambit but not easy
now to do okay it's going for a big
clamp here in the center with them with
F form but he's given up the bishop pair
which of course are always like to have
I wonder how to now open up the position
you know even c5 is a move normal would
be like b6 we should be seven and then
c5 but maybe this is not really not
really necessary okay I'm doing ce-5
immediately
not sure maybe b6 was more prudent but
this is certainly not bad for black wow
this move I absolutely didn't consider
because it completely wrecks the pawn
structure after Bishop b5 maybe the town
underestimate this in a way ok I'm going
to take care anyway question is what now
Queen g5 attacking on g2 maybe I'm
difficult for him now that you keep all
this stuff okay if I capture is he going
to play 95 allowing Queen g2 I could
also play Queen g2 here but you might
castle long after that okay let's just
recap sure and see what is doing now I
mean I mean I'm frightened I'm okay in
multiple ways it's not so easy to
determine what's the best way to play a
sewn on it okay I'm taking him and
trying to pressure rise III not bad I
could also try d for him it's a funny
pin d for Queen d4 Knight see to but he
might play 94 now i need to be a bit
quicker
he's mostly playing is playing quickly
and turn the main danger here will be a
time loss not lost due to the position
ok night see to then grab your knee
three maybe can also just take III but
that's not so brilliant let's let's go
here and capturing here the only problem
could be after them in sort of a pin
here you will pray rookie one now I
guess no hard time to guess anything
there should be six simply on the ship
d7 to c6 could also be a move keeping an
eye on a form else maybe not a bad idea
so I've one upon he's got no particular
compensation for it you can play against
e5 but I don't think he's so going to
win it yeah I have a hard time to guess
any of his moves really take Jackie to
now he wants to get the 50 mins and it's
not thats ok yeah we can take you five
but what about rook e8 night a flag just
winning it another pawn yeah 93 is also
not bad gaining c5 yeah that's even
better that's rookie one mate if it
moves Roxy two or something so I mean
I'm getting c5 it's even more important
than getting a four and A four is
sending anyway
yeah I really don't tell does he even
keep a for now white resigns yeah picked
all the pawns rather quickly yeah I was
a very surprised that he took on c5
which does not seem necessary at all why
am why spoil of the composite structure
completely I'm not sure how how bad it
really is but it looks it looks weird to
me too Linda this is full of weaknesses
I mean I'm a porn down but I will
certainly win at least one pound bag
instead I thought would just play let's
say yeah castles somewhere after which I
mean I'm satisfied with this position
but there's really nothing nothing
special going on and say something like
that then oh yeah be six maybe b6f he
cannot d5 it's not clear that it's so
great maybe you should try that down I
could also try this trying to avoid the
somewhat weakening of the c6 square
after v6 this looks normal but yeah I
don't know I mean boy you maybe needs to
do something crazy with long tassels but
I wrote yeah I think black is just more
comfortable or maybe maybe you could try
to build up pressure against e5 quickly
not that one but let's say let's say
something like that and now rook you one
or some things this may be an idea rook
c8 yeah I don't know this is this is
probably okay I mean it's equal material
c5 is weak but it's got queen deform
something like that right here it's it's
getting tricky already
I'm starting to pick up material I know
probably you can play it more precisely
in both sides but look quite quite okay
to me alright thanks for watching